RAPHAEL LEITERITZ:
Welcome, everyone.
Thanks for coming.
So this is another great
series of the Talks
at Google series where we
invite exciting [INAUDIBLE]
of speakers to Google to talk
about a great person's story.
So I have two guests that I'm
very honored to announce today.
It's Ruha.
Ruha was born in
Syria in Al-Hasakah
and she had to flee
Syria during the war.
And she didn't only
flee alone; she
flew with two sisters,
three cousins,
and a 96-year-old grandmother
on a rubber boat to Europe.
So she's going to tell
us about that story, how
she managed to do that, what
did that mean for her life.
And also she is now
working in a Swiss NGO
to help other refugees, and
she is a translator there.
So she hears not only her own--
she not only has
her own memories,
but also hears a lot
from other refugees
and has insights based on that.
And to end on a happy
note, I can already
tell you their family
was, in the end,
happily reunited in Sweden.
So it is somewhat of a happy
ending of a difficult story.
So welcome to Ruha.
And I have Ayesha over there--
Ayesha Keller.
She is Scottish, so she was
born in Edinburgh in '89.
She helped found an
NGO that takes care
for refugees that are
affected by the Syrian crisis.
builds-- For example,
she has projects
to build better housing--
dignified housing in Greece.
So that's a big part of the
story you're going to tell us--
what you did there,
and how that helps.
It's an NGO called
Together for Better Days.
We're going to hear about that
NGO specifically also a bit.
And actually, Ayesha also spent
a year on the ground in Greece.
It's a very
practical experience.
So I'm going hand
it over to Ayesha
to please tell us
about your story.
AYESHA KELLER: Thank
you very much, Raphael.
And thank you,
everyone, for coming.
Shall I-- thank you.
So we are going to tell
you our personal story
of this experience.
And then at the end, we'll be
very open to taking questions
as well.
So my story starts in Edinburgh,
in Scotland, where I grew up.
And I had a very
happy childhood--
a very protected childhood--
in a way, for many of us,
a very normal childhood.
And the closest I got to knowing
about war and the atrocities
that connected to that
was in my history lessons,
where I quite naively felt that
that was something in the past,
and we had obviously
learned from our mistakes,
and I would never--
I would luckily, would
never have to experience
something like that again.
As my activism was occasionally
marching with some friends
to make poverty
history, or whatever
it was that was happening
in the town at the time--
but yeah, I didn't expect
to ever really have
to deal with these things.
And I was very focused on
wanting to start a business.
So I went to university.
I studied in
Sunderland and Berlin,
and I also lived in Newcastle.
And studied business and did
quite a lot of traveling.
I also, after school,
went on a gap year
and traveled around the world.
And for me, freedom
of movement was just
something that was very
intrinsic to being human.
It was way before I even knew
of this expression of freedom
of movement.
I've lived in seven
different countries, traveled
in over 40--
it just seems quite
a normal thing to do.
So following my studies-- or
actually, during my studies,
I did an internship not so
far from here at the Bodensee.
Really beautiful place.
And there was also where I,
at the time, met my boyfriend.
And after finishing my studies,
we moved back to Zurich.
So I actually lived here
in Zurich for two years.
And my time in Switzerland
was really nice.
It's a beautiful country.
I had a very comfortable life.
I had a good job in a very
corporate environment.
And I had good career
progression opportunities.
Life was good.
Comfortable.
Possibly, after a while, I got
the feeling I was in a bubble.
And more and more, I was
hearing about the news around me
of what was happening in
the rest of the world.
And I just realized that I
was in a very small percentage
of people that had
a very easy life,
and that maybe that wasn't
the case for everyone.
And I just wanted to know
more about the world.
So that drove me to quit my
job and leave everything behind
in Switzerland.
And for the next
couple of months,
I was traveling through
Europe, interviewing
a lot of different companies,
a lot of startups all over--
and finding out about all
these different projects
and innovations and
things that were going on,
which were very interesting.
And during that
time, in November--
actually it was before then--
we saw that first
picture of Alan Kurdi
washed up on the
shores of Turkey.
And that's when the world media
became aware of the crisis,
and so I also became
aware of the crisis.
So it was in the
back of my mind,
and I had been thinking
for a while, yeah,
I like going to Greece;
that could be interesting--
or maybe Calais or maybe--
but didn't actually
take that step.
So when I saw a friend
of mine in November
had posted on Facebook
saying, I'm going to Greece.
And I commented saying,
that sounds amazing.
And she was like, oh, why
don't you come with me?
And five days later, I
was on a flight to Lesvos.
Only for a week
just to go and see,
because I felt that the
media representation must
be completely exaggerated.
There's no way
that in my Europe,
that respects human rights
and everything else,
that this could
possibly be happening.
So I just thought, might
as well go and have a look.
When I got there, what I
experienced and what I saw
touched and moved
me in such a way
that one year later,
I was still there.
So when we arrived in Greece, I
arrived at around the same time
as thousands of
other volunteers who
were arriving from all over
the world, and at the same time
that thousands of refugees
were also arriving.
So it was a big meeting of
people on a very small tourist
island.
And as you can see
here in the background,
those are mountains of Turkey.
And on the left, we've got this
little rubber dinghy and one
of the border patrol boats.
Most volunteers would arrive by
flying in on a budget airline
or getting a 10-euro
ferry from Turkey.
For the refugees, they
had to risk their lives
on incredibly overcrowded boats,
costing thousands per person,
depending which smuggler
they haggled with.
So it was a very, very
surreal experience.
And arriving there and
seeing what was going on,
it just felt unreal.
And I couldn't quite
come to terms with it.
And it was because of
that that, together
with other independent
volunteers,
we came together
and started an NGO.
It was not planned.
It was very much in response
to what was happening.
So in Greece, many,
many people arrived.
And we had-- yeah, it was one
of the biggest migrations we've
had since the Second World War.
And people would
arrive on the coasts,
and then once they had
arrived on the coast,
they would all come to Moria.
Moria was a central
registration center,
so everybody would
come through there.
We had volunteers also really
coming from everywhere,
like I said.
So in Moria, we set
up an organization.
At the time, it was called
Better Days for Moria.
And we had around--
it's hard to know
the exact numbers
because we didn't start
registrations till much later,
because it was really
a grassroots response.
So the process and
systems grew as we grew.
But we estimate probably
around 5,000 volunteers
came through our projects, and
around about the time, 200,000
refugees were arriving and went
through the project as well.
So a lot of people from a
lot of different countries.
While I was in
Switzerland, I lived
what one might, in many
ways, say was a normal life.
But in many ways, I felt
very disconnected from life.
And what I experienced in Lesvos
was so real, and so moving,
and so touching.
And this connection
with people was
just really beautiful and
tragic at the same time.
And this way that you would
build trust and connection
with people that you never
met before was really quite--
very, very special.
And so, in a way, felt more
real than anything else
I had experienced,
even though we were
in this very strange situation.
Yeah.
I really like this picture.
It's just one of
those experiences
of one of the many,
many, many people I met.
When people arrive, they often
had very wet shoes and feet.
And in the middle of the winter,
it gets very cold in Greece.
A lot of people don't realize
that it goes to minus degrees
and snows.
So one of the main things we did
when people got off the boats
was putting emergency
foil into the shoes
and giving people new socks.
So one lady I met--
never met her again.
No idea where she is,
but we had millions
of these connections
going on, which I think
was very beautiful.
So this is the camp.
This is the camp we set up
as Better Days for Moria.
It was the Olive Grove camp.
So at the peak of the
arrivals in October,
there were up to 10,000
people arriving per day.
The Moria registration
center officially
had capacity for a few hundred,
and if you crammed it full,
you could fit about 3,000.
But either way, you've
got a lot of extra people
who are not going to fit in.
So they're waiting on the
surrounding Olive Grove,
full up to a week,
sometimes longer,
depending how quickly the
registrations were happening,
depending--
we never really knew.
When there was a
government visit,
it all went really quickly.
When there wasn't
a government visit,
it could take a long time.
It really depended.
So we set up an
emergency response camp.
When we arrived in November,
the situation wasn't nice.
It was basically
full of rubbish.
People were burning
rubbish to stay warm.
There was no proper
accommodation.
There was no medical cover.
There was no food.
There were a lot of
volunteers sporadically
turning up and
trying to help out,
but there were no
real systems in place.
So we founded the
organization as a way
to bring some
structure to the chaos.
So we then, over time, together
with many other partners
and many other organizations,
had 24-hour medical care,
24-hour clothing
distribution, 24-hour food,
24-hour information, shelter,
everything like that.
So if people arrived at
2:00 AM, which was usually
the case-- people came at night.
Really wet, really cold,
in the middle of winter,
and there was a real
danger of hypothermia.
We could get people into dry
clothes as quickly as possible,
give them a warm
soup or warm chai,
and give them the
information they
needed as to what the next
steps were, and move people on.
So that was our main focus--
was the survival.
However, what underpinned that,
and always underpinned that,
was we also wanted to
make people feel welcome.
So the idea was, one,
we want you to survive--
really important,
and was a major topic
that we needed to work on.
But we also wanted to have
it like an oasis of warmth,
in a way, in a very
difficult journey.
We knew people had a
hard journey behind them.
We knew they would have a
hard journey ahead of them.
And we wanted a time when they
could come together and just
feel human and be
recognized as a human
being with hopes and
dreams and aspirations,
and not just as a statistic or
as a number on a registration
paper.
So a lot of what we did as well
was creating this community.
And most of our
services could not
have run if we didn't also have
the support of the refugees,
especially translation.
But everything-- so
clothing distribution, food
distribution-- we really
worked together as a community,
and that was very beautiful.
And I must say, we often got--
we had mainly single
men on our camp
because the priority
for inside the compound
was for family,
infants and children.
So at night, it was
mainly single men,
and they get so much bad press.
And people were like, oh
it'd be really dangerous
if you have thousands
of single men
from all over the
world in one camp.
They probably
fight all the time.
Absolutely not the case.
We had very little conflict.
Only when all the borders
closed and everyone
felt really desperate did any
kind of violence break out.
And even then, it was never
towards any of the volunteers,
and always quite more
in a protest manner
rather than in aggression
towards anyone.
It was a really
weirdly beautiful place
in amongst this complete chaos.
Yeah, this was our tea tent
where everyone who arrived
got served warm tea.
Then the borders
started closing.
And, well, it already
started for some people
around Christmas when the North
Africans could no longer cross,
and the Pakistanis
could no longer cross,
and the Afghans could
no longer cross.
I still remember the
morning I came up onto camp,
and there were just so many
Afghans outside the info tent.
And I was like, what's going on?
And they said, oh, our
friends at the Idomeni border
have just told us that the
Afghans can no longer cross.
So I called one of my friends
at the Idomeni border.
I was like, what's going on?
They said, yeah,
they just closed it,
but then they've
just reopened it
and let a few families through.
And now they've literally
just closed it again.
We're not really sure.
There was no official news.
So Moria was really
a place where
you could feel the crisis.
We found out about it
before it hit the news.
It was instant.
We're really this
bottleneck where you really
felt what was happening
along the whole route.
So once that happened,
then the EU-Turkey deal
came into effect
in March, which was
this agreement between
Europe and Turkey
that Turkey would try and
prevent people from coming.
And in return, Europe would
give them a lot of money
and they would resettle
people legally.
Unfortunately, it
doesn't really work.
And even then, we were
very, very skeptical of it.
The difficult thing
about the EU-Turkey deal
was it came into
effect overnight
before the papers had
even been released,
so nobody actually
knew what it was.
They just knew it was a
thing that had been agreed.
So the lawyers were all
scratching their heads
looking very confused.
The politicians were
making grand announcements
about how this was going
to solve everything.
And the people who were
actually responsible,
like the police and the
border controls and the army,
just didn't really know.
And so almost in a
kind of let's make
sure we don't make
a mistake response,
they just locked the
whole thing down.
And overnight, it
became a prison.
So suddenly, all the
children, the parents,
the unaccompanied minors, the
families, the men-- everybody
got locked into this
detention center.
It was incredibly overfilled.
And suddenly, our only
way to reach these people
was through fences again.
So we were having to pass
clothes and food and so
on through the fences.
And it was very sad,
because we had finally
established systems that worked,
and we felt quite confident.
And then overnight,
it all got destroyed.
In retaliation to
that, there was a lot
of protests inside the camp.
Most of the human
rights experts--
if not all of them-- plus
many of the world leader--
well, not world
leaders, but experts
in the field of human
rights and law and so on,
were saying that
the law was illegal.
Well, it wasn't a law;
it was an agreement.
And everybody was very confused
as to what was happening next
and what would happen.
So there was a lot of
peaceful protests happening
inside the camp for weeks.
This eventually--
after over a month
of nothing changing,
and not enough
food, and a lot of other
problems-- escalated
into rioting and more
extreme protesting
where things were burnt down.
Unfortunately, that's
incredibly effective.
Suddenly, the press turns up.
There's pressure, and
people were allowed out.
So unfortunately, often
the peaceful protests
have very little effect,
and violence does.
Again no one was hurt.
It was just burning down things
and making big "notice us"
moves.
Even when it was
open, it was still
kind of a detention
center because in order
to go through the
asylum process,
you have to wait for
your number to be called.
And the numbers get called
over the loudspeaker.
So if you go into town and
you missed your number being
called, you missed your chance.
So even though officially
the gates were open,
the systems weren't in place to
actually allow people to leave.
This meant we weren't
very happy either.
Suddenly, I ended up
at many, many protests.
Almost every day,
we were protesting,
speaking to journalists,
trying to raise our voices,
saying this is not OK.
We're not OK with this.
I never thought I was going
to end up an activist.
I thought I would spend most
of my life in a business suit.
And instead, suddenly, I
was there running around
with "we love you"
signs and a whistle,
trying to attract
attention to the fact
that I was not
OK, as a European,
having human rights
just walked all over.
During this time, I also
spent a lot of time speaking
to the press.
And they really came
from all over the world--
so this was Australia,
America, Germany, UK--
really, everywhere.
I did a lot of interviews.
And this was really nice.
And it was a very positive
experience for the refugees
as well because it felt like
they hadn't been forgotten
and there were people who cared.
Unfortunately now, people have
pretty much forgotten about it.
It's not in the news
very much anymore.
The conditions in
Moria now are worse
than they were a year ago.
And yet, you rarely
hear about it.
So it's actually a
shame that the media
has gone on to other stories,
like whatever else is going on.
So once Moria closed
and we realized
that we couldn't continue
doing anything there,
we lovingly said goodbye to
Lesvos, set up a legal program
to help the people inside Moria,
and went on to northern Greece,
which is where the main things
were happening with the Idomeni
border.
There, we set up a new
pilot project and refugee
accommodation.
This was quite an
interesting project
because it was a
public-private partnership.
So it was an official Greek camp
recognized by the government,
but funded by philanthropy money
from a Canadian philanthropy
organization and
run by volunteers,
which was our organization.
We rebranded this
Together for Better Days
because we were no longer
in Moria, and together
with the residents.
So here is one of
the forums we had.
And we really worked at
building dignified systems.
So rather than
handing out clothes,
we actually created
a clothing shop
where people have
credits, so they
can come in and buy things.
Actually really
recently, there's
a new development
from Techfugees,
who came in and did a study.
And they have set
up an IT system now
to be able to manage
all of that properly.
So there's a lot of innovation
and some really cool stuff
happening.
Again, our focus
was wanting to make
sure the basic minimum
standards were met.
We were the only camp
at the time-- possibly
still are-- in
northern Greece that
meets the basic
humanitarian standards that
was set up by Sphere,
even though they're
very, very basic.
And once we had that covered,
like no one is going to die,
then the focus is on education,
activities, and so on.
Basically, to keep
people entertained
until they get their decision,
which could be months.
And nobody knows.
They're literally just waiting.
They get a phone call,
and then they can go.
But there's no appointment,
so you're literally just
waiting and waiting.
And it can be a month.
It can be a year.
So there was lot of
frustration and boredom.
So that was one of the
focuses, on what can we
do while we're waiting.
The food was amazing.
[CHUCKLES] Really one of
the big things we had is we
realized, for people, cooking
is a very important part
of culture.
So we set up, again, a
market where people could
buy their stuff with credits.
And then they could cook
in the communal kitchen,
and would have big
community feasts.
And the really nice
thing about Elpida--
it means "hope" in Greek--
but the really nice thing was
that it was a community project
where people worked
together, and where
we worked with the
community to run this camp.
It worked really well.
The idea was it
would be a pilot,
and it would be rolled out
across many other places.
Unfortunately, it
hasn't for many reasons,
I guess-- mainly political.
So it's still there,
but it doesn't
look like it's going to
be copied at the moment.
We'll see.
But the options are there.
I think one thing that's
really important to be aware of
is that most of the
problems have been solved.
The solutions are there.
It's always the question if you
want to implement it or not.
And that's the main barriers
that we come across.
And it's the main reason
why I left Greece.
And I'm now going
around Europe talking
because I want to make people
aware that the solutions are
there.
We need to have a will
to implement them.
So my real wish
for the world would
be to end all war and conflict,
and all of those bad things.
But I know that's very
idealistic and Utopian,
and is probably not
going to happen.
But in the meantime,
I think what I really
hope is that we have this
courage to look for solutions
and not to give up, and to
keep our minds open and curious
and awake to try and find
solutions to these problems,
because they are there.
And we just need to have
the will to implement them.
[APPLAUSE]
RUHA SAID: Thank you, Ayesha.
I would like to thank everyone
to show up again, once more.
My name is Ruha Said.
I am from Al-Hasakah in Syria.
That is in the northern
eastern corner of Syria.
I grew up in a nice city--
actually a quite big city,
but the society I grew up in
was a simple society full
of many, many relatives.
I had a very happy childhood.
I went to private
primary school, and then
to a governmental school
secondary, and high school.
And then I had to
move to Damascus
to study at the university.
This is the Art and Humanitic
Science of Damascus University.
This is the facility.
And the society in Damascus
was much more different
than the society in Al-Hasakah.
It was a bigger society.
We were students
from all over Syria,
together sitting in
the same auditorium.
So it was a little
bit difficult for me
to blend in among
all these students.
But I, in some way, I
managed to get used to it.
And I made some
good friends, but I
am in touch with very, very
few of them at the moment.
And then in March 2011,
the revolution started.
My only definition of war was
the one I read in history books
in school.
But then I saw it happening
in front of my own eyes.
All the people were
shouting at the beginning
that this was a
peaceful revolution,
but this was not what the
government had in mind.
This is a picture of a
suburb of Al-Hasakah.
I was in Damascus when
it started to happen.
And I realized that everything
was changing really quickly.
We had soldiers and
guns all over the place.
Prices of food, of
books, of transportation
were doubled and then tripled.
And then we couldn't
feel secure anymore.
Like, fear and insecurity
were present in every step
of my life.
So I decided to quit
at the university
and then go back home.
And then I went back home
to find the market looks
like this.
Yeah.
It was not much different than
the situation in Damascus,
so we realized that we did have
to do something about this.
We realized that if you
wanted a better life,
then we have to move.
And me and my father used
to talk very frequently
about this situation.
And then we decided
to move on to Iraq,
but we couldn't due
to financial problems.
And then my father
traveled to Sweden.
And that was late February 2014.
And after that,
in September 2014,
I moved with my whole family
to Turkey, with my family
and with my aunt's family also.
We sold the house in order
to be able to move to Turkey.
I was working in
a sewing factory.
I started working right away.
We sew clothes for children.
And again, it was difficult for
me to fit in this new society,
with a new language, with
so many different people.
They were not similar
to where I grew up.
I was paid 700 Turkish lira.
That is less than 200
Swiss franc per month.
After a while, after
learning the language,
I felt myself a little
bit more or less getting
used to this new society.
I made a couple
of friends there.
And then December 2015, my
mother, my young brother,
and my youngest sister
were able to move to Sweden
through the family
reunification.
A couple of days
later, we found out
that we were rejected-- we,
as me, my two younger sisters,
and my 96-year-old grandmother.
We were rejected.
So we had no idea
what to do back then.
It was really hard
to think what to do.
And then, after
my mother leaving,
it was difficult
for me to go to work
and then leaving my sisters
with my grandmother back home.
And then I had to quit working.
And we had to make
the journey to Greece,
and then take the Balkan
route to try to go to Sweden.
This is my grandmother
on the boat.
Coming to Greece
was the experience
that changed my life.
Actually, the smuggler told us
that the boat would be a big
boat, but it wasn't.
We were supposed to be
15 people on the boat,
but we were 23 people.
And it was supposed to
be from a point that's
called Cesme in
Turkey, but it was
from a different one, a
more difficult, faraway one,
that takes much more time.
And we ended up in a place
on Lesvos island, a place
that volunteers say that
no boat has ever arrived
before nor after.
Yeah, so we were the
first and the last there.
The trip was very scary.
It was the scariest
part of my life.
And it's so strange that I can
remember each and every second
of that day.
When we were at the
point to take off,
we found out that
everything was a lie,
so we decided not to go forward.
We decided to go back, but
then searching for the cars,
everyone had disappeared.
No one was there.
They disappeared like lightning.
And so we had to
step into this boat.
I was the first one to go in,
And then my sisters and then
my grandmother.
My grandmother was
in complete absence.
She could not realize anything
of what's going around her.
I had one of my sisters--
each one of them clinging
to one of my arms,
screaming and crying, oh,
how we're going to die,
we're going to die.
As I could feel the boat
shaking and underneath my legs,
I couldn't think
or feel anything.
I was very scared, but I had to
act very strong for my sisters
and my grandmother.
It was really one of the
moments that I still--
I mean, talking about it,
it is still like a movie.
I cannot believe that
that has happened to me.
We started sailing.
The trip took three
and a half hours.
The engines stopped twice.
Everyone was in complete panic.
I tried calling the
Greek coast guards,
but they put my call on wait.
That was of no help.
And then the only moment
that I can clearly remember
was the moment when
I lift up my head,
and I could see this
huge mountain beside me.
You can see this
is that mountain.
This is the island.
This is the place
where we landed.
Yeah, we could land
safely, thank god.
And we had to climb up
the hill and in the dark.
And we were hearing all
the voices from animals.
We were very scared.
But my grandmother was really
tired and we couldn't climb up,
so we had to go back.
And then out of nowhere,
this yellow van shows up.
I had no idea that there
were volunteers at that time.
I had no idea that the borders
were closed at that time.
I was thinking that this
is a matter of 10 days,
and I would be home safe,
but it took me six months
to arrive at last.
This van showed
up, and the woman
sitting in front,
Raquel [? Hertzel-- ?]
she was the first
person I speak to.
I ran to her and
I asked for help.
Please can you help us?
We have two old ladies with us,
and we need help right away.
So everyone was
on the run, and we
were taken to the main street.
And then we were taken by
police buses to the Moria camp,
where we registered.
And then we stayed
there for a night.
And finding out the
situation in Moria
was completely difficult
for my grandmother
to survive, I had
to find a better
place with the small
amount of money I had.
We rented a room.
It was more or less
a room with 10 beds.
We stayed there for
a couple of nights,
and then Raquel helped
me to find an apartment.
And then she helped
me to work with NGOs--
with the organizations there.
And the only thing that I
am most thankful for is I
was able to go back to
that place in daylight.
This is how it looks.
This was one of the
moments that I can never
forget because this
was the time I realized
that that place was not ugly.
That place was not scary.
It was actually a
beautiful place.
It was one of the most beautiful
places I have ever seen.
And that's why I could feel
a little bit more safe--
a little bit more comfortable
about moving on and continuing
living.
I was able to work
as a volunteer.
We the SAO with Together for
Better Days-- oh, actually,
at that moment, it was
Together for Better--
AYESHA KELLER: Better
Days for Moria.
RUHA SAID: Better
Yeah.
I was there to--
this is one of
the boat arrivals.
I really wanted to be at
one of the boat arrivals.
And this was one of
the experiences that
really moved me and touched me.
The boat was from Iraq.
They were all Kurdish people,
and all the volunteers there
were Arabic.
They were yelling at the
people in Arabic like,
stop, don't put your
children in the water--
but no one seems to understand.
I was shaking before
that, but then I
realized that these
people need help.
So I ran to the boat as I was
screaming in Kurdish like,
stop, you cannot put
your children into water.
These are good people.
They are volunteers.
They will help you.
They will welcome you.
And yeah, that was one
of the moments that
made me much more stronger--
that shaped my personality more
or less.
And then from that time on,
I did work with many NGOs,
with journalists, with directors
from the UK, from the US,
and Raquel helped
me to find a lawyer
to appeal the rejection
decision we had,
but the appeal was
rejected once more.
And then, at last, I had
to take a plane to Sweden.
And this was the moment me
and my grandmother arrived.
My grandmother, again,
did not realize anything.
She only realized the
fact that we were reunited
when she saw my mother--
there, on the right of the
picture-- she started crying.
And a couple days
after we arrived,
Raquel visited us in Sweden.
And yeah.
That was most of it.
Thank you.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ:
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ:
Maybe to follow up,
Ruha, on what
you-- so I actually
have two questions to you.
So the one is, if I
understand correctly,
you had to flee twice, right?
You fled--
RUHA SAID: Yeah.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ:
--your hometown?
RUHA SAID: Yeah.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: And
then you went on the boat.
RUHA SAID: Yeah.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: In
each of those moments,
can you talk a bit more
about what that means?
I mean none of us have
experienced that, right?
What's the moment when you
realize, I have to do this?
RUHA SAID: None
of us knows that.
And I wish none of
us would ever be
forced to go through
that experience,
because it is really
difficult that you have
to leave everything you know--
the whole places, your
studies, everything.
You have to leave them behind
you and then go to a place
where you have no clue--
where you have zero
skills, language.
And it's really difficult.
But the situation was really
hard in Syria, and then
in Turkey.
It was really hard that you
realize that you cannot take
this anymore.
Like in Syria, the
war is really--
in my home town, there
wasn't bombing all the time.
But the military was there,
present all the time.
Each 10 days, we had a car
bombing, or a person bombing,
and then people dying.
And then you have prices
going up like crazy.
People aren't able to go study.
Life literally stops.
And then you realize it's
either me taking a step forward,
or me accepting dying
slowly in this place.
And that's why you
will say nothing
is more difficult than
staying here, then moving on,
but staying here.
So I chose to move
on in both times.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: You
mentioned you had smugglers.
You had people that helped
you or try to help you.
Talk a bit about the
logistics, because I
guess it's so hard to
imagine for us, right?
How did you know what to do?
Did you always get help?
Did you get the right help?
This must be crazy logistics.
RUHA SAID: I really
didn't know what to do.
I had no idea what I'm doing.
I had no idea that is
the right thing to do.
Would this be acceptable?
Would this do good,
or would it be bad?
Would it bring me
to a worse place?
But I was lucky.
I was really lucky in each time.
I was lucky in Turkey to
meet a couple of good people.
And I was lucky in
Greece to meet people
like Raquel and Ayesha.
Yeah, I think it's
very difficult
to define the logistics,
but they are there.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: Yeah.
If I can turn it to
Ayesha, and maybe
ask you a couple of questions--
So you mentioned
things have evolved
a bit since you went there.
Can you maybe
summarize again, how
is the situation better or
worse or different from when
you first went there to today?
AYESHA KELLER: So it's
incredibly different.
I think that one of the reasons
the news has kind of forgotten
about it is because the
arrival numbers have
dropped significantly.
There still are hundreds of
people arriving every week,
so it's still quite
a lot of people,
but compared to the thousands
before, it's a huge drop.
So I think it feels,
in a way, when
you look at it from
the outside, it's
as if it's not bad
because you don't
have those scenes of so many
people and lying on the beach,
and children being washed
up, and things like that.
However, unfortunately, because
there's no movement forward
anymore and because a lot
of the borders are closed,
the schemes aren't
really working.
People are stuck.
And so they're stuck
behind these fences,
and they just don't know
what's going to come next.
So the desperation--
the depression
is just getting really
quite unbearable
for many, many people.
The main difference is
it's become kind of quiet.
It's become the
silent, invisible pain
that people have,
which, in a way,
is a lot more dangerous because
it's a lot easier to ignore.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: You mentioned
you're now active in this NGO
that you co-founded, right?
Talk a bit about what
you can do from here now,
since you're not on
the ground anymore.
You mentioned a
few things already,
but what are the goals?
Where can you influence?
Where can you actually--
AYESHA KELLER: Slides--
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ:
--support something?
AYESHA KELLER: --going back one.
There we go.
There are many ways
you can get involved.
Really easy, obvious
ones are donating,
but it doesn't have to be that.
I think one of the
most important things
is to stay informed.
I think one of the main reasons
these things are happening
is because people
aren't really aware.
I always think if people
really knew what was happening,
it wouldn't happen.
But it's quite easy to
ignore, especially if people
aren't reporting on it.
I think it's really important
to meet refugees and speak
to people and realize
that they're just humans.
I think, for me,
meeting Ruha in Greece
was a really amazing
experience because she
speaks so good English.
And my Arabic is pretty
much non-existent,
so until that moment,
I hadn't really
had a chance to have a
really good conversation
with another woman
in my age, basically.
And sitting down
with her made me
realize it could have been me.
I was born in Scotland,
not Syria, but who knew?
Like, neither of us would have
known this was going to happen.
And I think that realization
that we're just the same,
actually, it really helps to
put everything into context.
So I think it's
important, rather
than seeing some of the--
I don't know how
is in Switzerland.
In the UK, the media is
very afraid of refugees.
All the headlines are
basically about fear,
and I think it's very easy
to be afraid of something
you don't understand.
If you understand and
you know the person,
you can't be afraid of them.
I don't think I could
be afraid of you.
[LAUGHTER]
Maybe sometimes.
But no, in general,
it becomes ridiculous.
I mean, we're even
laughing about the idea.
It's completely insane.
And it is.
But how would you know if I
hadn't had that interaction?
So I think that's very helpful.
And I think keeping an open
mind is really important,
and speaking up.
So when people say
things about refugees
that you maybe don't agree
with, that you say, hey,
I actually don't agree
with that, or even,
why exactly do you think that?
Have you actually
spoken to someone?
Where are you getting
these figures from?
Because a lot of these figures
are also vastly inflated.
I think it's really
important to be aware
that in 2015, around
850,000 people came over
from Turkey to Greece, and
that meant they were all
trying to get into Europe.
That meant Europe increased
its population by 0.2%.
In Lebanon, at the moment, we've
got an increase of about 20%,
25%--
depends which statistics
you're looking at.
So it's a huge difference.
0.2% is kind of nothing.
And so, in a way, people get
so afraid of these big numbers,
but when you put
it into comparison,
it suddenly isn't
that big a number.
So it just needs to
be managed properly,
and then you don't
have the issues.
I'm not saying there aren't
problems; there are problems.
But I think the problems are to
do with the way the crisis has
been managed and
the way solutions
have been implemented, and
not because of the situation.
0.2% isn't a big deal.
If you don't manage it properly,
it can become a big deal.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: If I may
turn it to Ruha again, and just
ask you, because you mentioned
already you were a translator.
On the ground, in a sense.
It sounded like you
turned from a refugee
to a supporter at some
point, isn't that right--
which is, I think, amazing.
And I can see why that
was important for you.
How is that today?
I mean, are you actively
working with that NGO?
What is your role in that?
And what are your
connections, actually?
RUHA SAID: I would
have to say that it
had a very big part in shaping
me and in making me, me.
I am much more
stronger than I was,
and I am still working with
SAO as a cultural advisor.
Hopefully, we are planning to
open a women's center in Greece
and that's still planned.
There is not much about
that, but hopefully.
And I'm still in touch with
many of the women I knew--
with many of the women I met.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ:
And may I ask,
did you exchange phone
numbers or Facebook?
How do you stay in
touch with people
that you meet under such
desperate conditions?
RUHA SAID: Yes, we did
change Facebook contact
because the phone numbers
were really unstable.
Yeah.
We changed Facebook
contact and I am still,
as I said, in contact
with many of them.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: Good.
Then I would say, I want
to thank you really,
very, very much for sharing
your personal stories
and what you do.
I want to thank you,
everybody, for coming.
And want to end it with here.
Thanks a lot, both of you.
RUHA SAID: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]